and finally new rule Republicans have to
stop pretending they hate it when
celebrities give their political
opinions please you're the party that
made Reagan president it's not our fault
that you're celebrities or Ted Nugent
Pat Sajak and Donald Trump James Woods
his last credit was on a MasterCard bill
Scott Baio the only thing he's been in
recently that made headlines was his
co-star Antonio sabato jr. was an
underwear model who all the other
underwear models referred to as the dumb
woman and after he spoke at the last
Republican convention he claimed he was
blacklisted in Hollywood blacklisted
blacklisted be an upgrade
he wasn't on any list be lucky to get on
the Do Not Call list you'd have to run
him into show business
[Laughter]
and he's running for Congress now as is
clueless actress Stacy - who was also in
the movie clueless at Obama's inaugural
gala he had Beyonce Springsteen Sheryl
Crow Bon Jovi Mellencamp uh sure Stevie
Wonder goth Brooks Tom Hanks Denzel and
you to Trump's inauguration had Jackie
Evancho on the rock BAM three doors down
as in three doors down from Fame and
then there's Dana lash who America has
come to know as the fiery voice of the
NRA blaming gun violence and all our
problems on Hollywood and it's
liberalism they use their movie stars
and singers and comedy shows and award
shows to repeat their narrative over and
over again fight this violence of lies
with the clenched fists of truth yes yes
I know what you're thinking who hurt you
Danica Patrick
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what you may not know about Dana lash is
that before her job as NRA spokesmodel
she was a show business wanna be a
homemaker in st. Louis with a mommy blog
and a radio show and dreams of TV
stardom
NCIS producer Paul Gyo says that ten
years ago
Dana pitched him a sitcom starring
herself as quote a hot young mom who
does a far-right radio show think
Frazier meets awful and you know what if
only they had made that sitcom today she
might be a completely normal person
instead we're all getting the clenched
fist of truth because show business gave
her the raise finger of [ __ ] off
[Music]
the same thing happened to both the
founder of the right-wing Breitbart
website Andrew Breitbart who admits he
came to Hollywood with the hope that I'd
eventually become a comedy writer and to
his successor there Steve Bannon also a
showbiz reject who didn't have the
talent to cut it here and so spent the
rest of his life hating Hollywood and by
extension all liberals in his memoir
Breitbart mentions Reagan six times and
me 34 times he called celebrities
elitist pestilence with their cocktail
parties on the west side god I [ __ ]
hate them he said which is funny because
you know for years you know who had
always see at cocktail parties on the
west side Andrew Breitbart oh he hated
Hollywood hated it hated it hated it
mostly from his home in America's
heartland Brentwood
[Laughter]
as for Bannon George Clooney remembers
him as quote a schmuck who who literally
tried everything he could to sell
scripts including this is true a rap
musical of Shakespeare's Coriolanus well
think Hamilton but instead of founding
fathers Romans and instead of cultural
phenomenon piece-of-shit Battin lost his
shirt on that deal but luckily he was
wearing three more but trust me if
Bannon could have sold a screenplay or
Breitbart a sitcom they wouldn't have
ended up ranting and raving about
cocktail parties on the west side they'd
be attending them and in bannon's case
finishing the drinks people left on the
table
[Applause]
including the ones with a cigarette in
them and so that is why I implore
tonight all Hollywood execs next time a
conservative comes to you with the
really dumb idea for a movie or a TV
show just [ __ ] do it
[Music]
we need affirmative action for
Republicans in show business they're not
good enough to make it on their own but
if we give them a leg up maybe they
won't take the rejection out on the
whole country